salut apparemment 2022 c'est l'année des
gros casse-tête avec l'aps terium ya
quelques temps l'aps terium vous savez
ce qui crée des casse-têtes dingue or
une commande un peu spécial de la part
d'une boutique de jeux qui s'appelle je
raconte c'est du côté de doué la
fontaine la dame qui s'occupe de sa
bombe de l'île leur a fait créer un beau
casse tête qui va mettre dans ce dans sa
boutique et elle a dit si vous voulez
avants fabien olicard il peut le tester
nous on a reçu le mail de l'aps terrien
on a fait oui et c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui on va le faire est-ce que
vous êtes prêts pour ce nouveau gros
casse-tête bien stylé mais surtout
surtout bien gros en fait il est gros
loïc gros ce sera le titre de cette
vidéo
où elle n'est pas perdu et il va
diffuser leurs idées au fort
avant de commencer laissez moi vous dire
que cette vidéo est sponsorisé par miles
heure par quoi parminder
minder
binder pourquoi minder tout simplement
parce que cette appli est juste très
utile aujourd'hui on parle de plus en
plus du mental sur les réseaux sociaux
mais aussi de la santé mentale et sur ce
deuxième point c'est parfois pas facile
de s'entourer pour se préserver et
justement c'est là que miles heurts
interviennent my mind of mind leur mind
l'heure
c'est une application mobile mais c'est
surtout un ensemble de sons en ligne qui
permet de mettre en relation des
psychologues d'un côté des patients de
l'autre et qui a été fondée par deux
psychologues et un médecin plus de 30
psychologues salariés sont disponibles
sur l'application recruter chacun pour
leur compétence et leur spécialité il en
tous diverses approches et spécialités
différentes tels que le stress l'anxiété
les tcl estime de soi des troubles du
sommeil la dépression le deuil et
beaucoup d'autres c'est une solution
moderne efficace pratique en plus le
delà des prises de rendez vous avec des
psychologues mind leur propose également
de nombreux modules et exercices pour
travailler en toute autonomie différents
sujets entre les séances ou bien
peut-être comme première approche parce
que peut-être vous n'êtes jamais allé
voir un psychologue vous n'êtes pas
encore assez année est ce pour faire une
consultation c'est possible si vous
voulez découvrir mendler vous invite à
passer bien le lien que j'ai mis dans la
description et utiliser mon code très
facile c'est fabien olicard
ça vous permet de bénéficier de -50% sur
une consultation directement sur
l'application n'hésitez pas à utiliser
ce code l'offre ne vous engage à rien
donc c'est peut-être l'occasion de
pouvoir tester l'application en prenant
un premier rendez vous pour débuter une
thérapie ou juste pour prendre le temps
pour une fois de parler à quelqu'un qui
sera vous écouter merci à mein l'heure
pour ce partenariat merci à vous de
m'avoir écouté merci loïc pour ce
cadrage merci la vie pour le fait que je
sois encore là malgré le coc vite que
j'ai eus récemment que j'en parle à
quelqu'un
c'est parti on va commencer déjà par le
retourner
[Musique]
pour voir s'il n'y a pas un truc du sens
et car un congrès on va faire une
exploration plutôt classique on va
partir de bases en haut
il ya de 4,6 côté c'est ça oui c'est ça
c'est un hexagone comme la france avec
de magnifiques statuettes qui sont
poussés poser s'il ya un petit ours
d'accord donc les statuettes elles sont
posées sur des socles qui n'ont pas le
même nombre de côtés d'ailleurs si on a
un octogone la barre on un carré et là
on a un
on dit au pentagone comme le pentagone
pentagone en géométrie un pentagone est
un polygone à cinq sommets donc c'est un
côté et 5 diagonale mais nous rejetons
ensemble
de
3-3 4-4 que cinq mois j'ai compris
pourquoi le pentagone s'appelait le
pentagone c'est incroyable ensuite de ce
côté là qu'est ce qu'on a on a un [ __ ]
ya beaucoup d'informations sur les côtés
je pense qu'il y en a beaucoup qui
servent à rien évidemment là on a des
petits boutons on va appuyer dessus
parce que sinon c'est pas marrant ici on
a une lettre que je vais dire après ici
on a un damier
c'est interdit bizarre parce que c'est
un 5 sur 5 ici on n'a qu'à se marrant ça
ça me rappelle les trucs où il faut
relier les points c'est une girafe choco
puisqu'on connaît la jirs d'accord il ya
des planètes il ya des chiffres des
chiffres qui se répètent des planètes
qui se répète de ce côté là on a aussi
une lettre qui semble aller avec la
lettre qu'il ya de l'autre côté parce
qu'il ya mon nom et je crois que j'ai lu
ni coolus de l'autre côté et je pense
qu'il faut associer les deux leila ya
clairement une une petite trappe en deux
grâce 1954 mon nom et nicodemus et je me
fais vieux cette inflation sera ma
dernière et j'espère mon héritage loup
solitaire je cherche en mai dernier jour
un peu de chaleur maintenant pour me
présenter j'ai commencé ma vie un simple
observateur un peu comme un oiseau
perché sur sa branche de cette
observation de la nature m'est venue un
goût pour compte en plein les nuages bon
attend comme un oiseau perché sur sa
branche contemplant les nuages là il ya
un oiseau je peux le mettre face au
nuage ou
peut-être faire ça devient de cette
observation de la nature m'est venue un
goût pour la compréhension de ces
mécanismes les plus merveilleux de
l'hélice de la graine d'érable au
camouflage de l'insecte nous avons tant
à apprendre
là il ya un insecte
donc face à l'insecte est ce qu'il ya
une graine d'érable la
dire que ça c'est un érable apparemment
maintenant au crépuscule
mais maintenant crépuscule de ma vie je
rentre dans ma grotte pour hiberner et
je tourne le dos au soleil qui met blue
huit ans je tourne le dos au soleil qui
hibernent lui il tourne le dos au soleil
parce que sa salle l'éblouît temps
insectes grain d'érable
se serait pas pour lui attends je pense
que l'ours
parce que luis mejia pas de soleil choc
ou [ __ ] c'était ça ok
alors attend lui en vrai je les ai eus
je les ai eus je lui sans le vouloir
lice étaient de l'hélice de la graine
d'érable au camouflage de l'insecte nous
avons tant à apprendre
et je pense que c'est le fait d'avoir
relié les deux en fait genre de lui à
lui face à lui lui il hibernait dont ils
étaient deux soleils et lui s'étaient
l'oiseau qui contemplait les nuages ça
nous a ouvert ça c'est pas mal de lire
un texte de tout seul si vous lisez ceci
alors vous avez été assez malin pour
déchiffrer les premières pages de mon
codex bravo je peux maintenant écrire
sans astuce ou bien tu es pourquoi
pourquoi rajouter des couches nicodemus
j'ai toujours vécu dans mon monde
jusqu'à être ramené à la réalité d'une
manière assez brutale par un petit
groupe que l'on nomme l'acquisition
brutale l'inquisition voulez voir un
petit verdot wiba voici neuf litres
parce qu'ils arrivèrent mes amis et moi
étions assis sur une vaste étendue
d'herbe un tapis parfait pour contempler
la rivière qui avait presque la couleur
de l'océan mais nous profitons également
de la chaleur du feu et là c'est alors
que les hommes de l'inquisition
débarquèrent émeutes renner de force à
l'atelier pour me confronter aux mal
irréparable que j'avais fait ils
détruisent hermé invention tout sauf
mais précieuse planche astral que
j'avais dit streit distraitement laisser
un peu partout dans mon atelier ça m'a
l'air d'être les planches astral fait
sur du vitrail il y en a dans quatre
bleus une verte ou non rouge
et une noire alors qu'est ce qui donne
ces coins c'est coin ils sont tous
identiques eu vent que les couleurs qui
change est ce qu'ils font la taille de
quelque chose du style par exemple ici
ici c'est pas mal du tout c'est les
mêmes symboles on va récupérer la lettre
ci lui je le mettais comme ça
il fait vraiment un trajet quoi
[Musique]
passe par deux des lunes si je ne
retourne dans ce sens cela passe par
deux hélas ils tentent comme ça ah bah
là là c'est pas mal là ça passe partout
comme on dit à fort boyard ça nous fait
soleil
3,4 soleil
ici elle soleil ce qu'il faudrait faire
1 2 3 1 2 3 4
est-ce qu'on rentrerait des combinaisons
de 3,14 ça veut rien dire ici j'ai pas
vu le symbole de piquer pas on va
regarder ce que ça fait avec les autres
planches la lune ça nous fait 3/4 de la
jeu peut glaner toutes ces infos là mais
assure qu'il me serait utile je vais les
planches dans le bon sens ensuite lui
323 pour une sorte de saturne on va dire
si je les cumuls est quand même mais bon
sens mais on va les faire se chevaucher
si je l'aimé comme ça c'est dans le bon
sens donc déjà le dessin me dit rien du
tout alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait ça
maintenant lune saturne soleil est-ce
que juste je cumule le nombre de trucs
j'ai envie de cumuler noms de la cuisine
que lui et me dit
ça ce texte là en italique ça m'intrigue
gel intime qui cache quelque chose en
même je le trouve l'écrit bizarrement
mais dans le genre et même dans le
rythme lorsqu'ils arrivèrent mes amis et
moi étions assis sur une vaste étendue
d'herbe
[Musique]
7 8 9
8 15 9 2 3 6 7 vies
dommage on n'y croyait pas en fond nous
essayons d'y voir plus clair les amis
pour cela ce sont les lunettes je vous
chose un petit 36 ans n'a pas j'ai pas
vu de code couleur quelque part ah si si
j'en air dans la lettre un code couleur
vitalic là je vous l'avais dit là
lorsqu'ils arrivèrent mes amis et moi
étant et ton étant étendue sur une vaste
étendue d'herbe vers un tapis parfait
pour contre plantes contempler la
rivière bleue nous profitons également
de la chaleur du feu rouge pour observer
les étoiles que la nuit tombe raynouard
je sais pas à quoi ça m'avance mais on
est d'accord que c'était bizarre ce
texte là déjà on à l'ordre des choses
est-ce qu'il faut que je tape toutes les
combinaisons dans cet ordre je vais vous
dire si c'est exactement ce que je vais
faire donc sa c4 soleil une lune et de
saturne quatre soleils de 3,4 une lune
crack et de saturne de we are now c'est
rocky qui tue la ya un petit truc qui
s'allume et comme pour me récompenser ça
fait zizir 3 soleil de lune 3 saturne 3
soleil de lune saturne
oui
trois saturn quatre soleils 2003 saturn
quatre soleils
de lune boom trois lunes un saturn et
quatre soleils trois lunes
un saturn 4 soleil
[Musique]
c'est bien ça fait pas peur du tout
on a du matos qui vient d'apparaître un
truc qu'on sait pas encore bien se
passer mais j'ai envie de souffler
dedans ça ça doit être la feuille numéro
5 si tout va bien qu'est ce qu'on trouve
également on trouve des petits morceaux
de bois qu'on peut pas retirer
l'impression pour le moment mais ont
foncé pour le moment lorsqu'on est un
peu un taquin si vous connaissez pas
c'est un jeu qui taquinent atteint il
m'a saoulé ce truc mais c'était trop
bien vous savez c'est pour ça que le
casse-tête s'écoule à faire parce que si
vous en faites pas vous connaissez pas
le sentiment du j'ai compris et il est
très agréable associée aux sentiments du
du marqueur qui te conforte que c'est ok
là c'était les petites lunes qui
s'allume et là j'étais toujours en fuite
de l'inquisition craignant pour ma vie
gérait déjà depuis des mois et ayant
traversé une bonne partie du pays quand
je pars vers l'entrée d'un bien étrange
village les habitations y ont été
creusées dans la roche quelle créature
pouvait vivre là non prend des bêtes
mais des humains j'ai appris alors à
faire connaissance avec ces personnes
qu'il est un homme des troubles au dit
elle vivait dans le secret de la pierre
froide et portant quelle chaleur mais
voyant désemparés les troubles dit me
recueillir
d'abord pour une soupe et remorques pain
puis une nuit ou deux le temps de me
remettre de mes émotions j'étais
désormais en sécurité je connais alors
un renouvellement d'inspiration
complètement fou c'est à cette époque
que je tombais notamment sur une de mes
plus fier trouvaille la lumière capable
de révéler l'invisible la lumière qui
révèle l'invisible
est-ce que ça serait pas une loupiote
mais ça au
hockey on est sur vous c'est les
lumières qui font apparaître ses
lumières electrabel est en fait un qui
peuvent faire apparaître des messages
cachés et de ce côté-là rien ce côté là
a priori rien sur elle la lettre qui
avait ici ne semble pas recéler de
détails cachés je moi je tends à penser
vous voyez je tends à penser qu'il ya
quelque chose de caché sur la boîte et
c'est le kart ici j'ai une tête de con
d'or avec un petit scarabée lui là bas
on va le mettre face au scarabée à ce
scarabée suite du coup est ce que j'en
ai d'autres ailleurs kg le loup à côté
de l'eau c'est toi le loin où ils se
trouvent tous les loups loulo
me regarder en haut parce que moi si
j'ai conçu cette boîte j'en aurait caché
là juste pour faire
[Musique]
l'ours est l'arbre l'ours regarde
l'arbre l'ours regarde l'arbre
ok ça fait tomber quelque chose dans la
sorte de taquin que j'avais vu tout à
l'heure et je crois que c'est un taquin
d'ailleurs je pensais pas qu'on
réutilise ray les statuts qui avait au
dessus et quand je disais ça ressemble à
un taquin c'est un taquin c'est à dire
qu'en fait les pièces elles coulisses et
on peut lire des choses en dessous en
fait là y'a marqué lorsqu'il se couche
5 heures
des deux la même
lorsqu'il y à l majuscule il ya des
trois petits points si parce qu'ils se
couchent 5 heures
donc lors ce qu'il se couche le soleil
elle se lève 5 heures plus tard la lune
les deux éclairant
à tour de rôle la même chose deux fois
par jour
moi je suis d'accord moi j'ai envie
d'être d'accord nicodemus d'accord une
fois que j'ai dit ça serve parce que là
je vois pas quoi actionner
parce que je reprends d'un système de
rotation pour les airs en plus là j'ai
un peu le soleil et la lune un peu
traficote un peu ce que je lis que ça
corresponde à ce qu'on appelle le biais
de confirmation et et cognitive et aux
confirmations j'ai envie que tout
correspondent à ce que je suis en train
de me dire en gros là ma difficulté je
pense que j'ai déco des messages comme
il le fallait c'est à dire lorsqu'il se
couche elle se lève 5 heures plus tard
les deux clairan la même chose deux fois
par jour et que c'est tout ce qui a à
faire avec le tac ce que je n'ai pas vu
de caches secrètes de choses à vous
appuyer de trucs comme ça et du coup ma
difficulté maintenant c'est quoi
actionnées entre guillemets avec ces
informations sachant qu'on a exploité
chacune des faces sauf et les chéquiers
je vois pas trop comment il pourrait
correspondre entre guillemets à quelque
chose dont j'aurai besoin maintenant je
n'aime pas de représentation de soleil
lune dessus là on va pas se mentir ça
fait dix minutes que je galère avec
cette phrase j'ai que ça au jeu peut
activer la qu'un endroit où je peux
faire des appuis c'est là lorsqu'il se
couche elle se lève 5 heures plus tard
il est clair la même chose deux fois par
jour ce 1 1 2 3 4 5
et se couche une fois
elle se lève 5 heures plus tard 5 il est
quand même chose deux fois par jour 2 je
voulais me suicider parce que je pense
que j'ai bien passé 15 20 minutes
vraiment sur cette partie d'énigmes au
lit chéquier il va servir à le sommes
c'était si bêtes au final c'est mais
c'est me paraissait pas possible ça nous
fait passer à la suite donc là c'est 7 8
ok on va aller directement à l'échiquier
je pense paquet de choses à voir ici
j'ai refait ma vie auprès des
troglodytes angevin j'ai pris la
décision d'enseigner la lecture et les
sciences aux enfants locaux car la
connaissance doit être transmise il se
montre briand bien plus même que le
blanc bec des cours dhoble parce qu'ils
n'ont ni exigence ni a priori prenons un
exemple simple la jeune anaïs 9 ans elle
ne savait pas que monter et se montrer
un peu réfractaires aux courses que je
peux comprendre j'ai donc choisi de lui
enseigner à cesson heureusement je dois
dire les mathématiques qu'elle n'aimait
pas en passant par le jeu la
gamification il avait tout compris
nicodemus une chose que je dois avouer
et que j'ai toujours une faiblesse
distingue pour le jeu d'échecs les
échecs ne l'est peut-être pas aidé à
anaïs a compté les oeufs de poule mais
j'ai pensé qu'il la mettrais dans un bon
état d'esprit pour découvrir la logique
et le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que
l'élève a dépassé le maître à la vitesse
de l'éclair voilà l'état de notre parti
juste avant canalis qui jouait les
blancs de me mettre maths en un seul
coup je me souviens encore très
exactement de ce moment le majestueux
roi immaculé oncle blanc se tenait
fièrement au centre du plateau son
adversaire lui faisait face au nord qu
on va dire que l'ours est ici qu il
était soutenu par son seul allié
immobilisé sur une case clair à gauche
de lui son seul allié du coup c'est lui
et du combat aurait donc de lui au final
le cavalier blanc lui était plus isolée
restant dans un des coins alors que le
fou patienter attendait patiemment en d1
que son moment viennent
d'un certain d anaïs avait certes l
avantage en nombre mais je pensait
encore pouvoir m'en sortir jusqu'à ce
qu'elle me même atteint en un seul coup
j'avais pas vu venir alors à laver quoi
elle a joué les bleus en cavale m matin
d'un seul coup c'est l'état note de la
partie avant il lui il est en d1 donc là
pour l'instant là il peut pas aller ici
l'appel droit ne peut pas aller là il
peut pas aller là il peut pas aller ici
il peut par contre aller ici ici ou ici
j'aime être comme ça pour regarder
l'état du jeu parce qu'après il faut
trouver où mettre le cavalier impro
finale et qui peut mettre ton de me
tenir le fou mais par en bas pourquoi me
gênait ma vision du centre merci
beaucoup de l'eau donc moi je suis ici
l'idée au centre là il n'a pas le droit
d'aller ici il n'a pas le droit d'aller
là il n'a pas le droit d'aller là il n'a
pas le droit d'aller là n'a pas le droit
d'aller là là faut que j'aille talent
elle met ma tante est donc là c'est pas
bon système concret
merci lolo à c'était le cavalier blanc
le chu bed en plus ce n'est pas un
cavalier noir pour le mettre en échec et
oui je suis noir mais même au moins en
fait ce qu'on veut c'est mettre en échec
oui j'étais en train de mettre en échec
le blanc
il va se faire manger
ne pas le mettre en marche donc est ce
que le but c'est que
c'était qu'elle ne mettra ok c'est bon
ok donc là on regarde le maître maths en
faisant son déplacement
on la bâche il s'est passé quelque chose
c'est de la felix felicis je la
reconnais c'était n'est qu'au début ce
qu'ils avaient du coup ça veut dire que
nicodème n'est qu'au début c'est harry
potter très bien c'est très stylée c'est
la dernière lettre de nico on l'appelle
nico on connaît maintenant nous voilà
arrivés au bout de l'aventuré et moi au
bout de mon histoire je n'ai jamais
quitté les troglodytes qui m'ont
accueillie pourquoi le ferait il sont
mes amis ma famille les enfants à qui
j'ai appris à lire et à compter à
agrandir ont grandi et remplace
facilement ce que je n'ai jamais eu moi
même sur ses bons mots permettez moi de
vous dire au revoir et vous souhaiter
une longue vie longue et heureuse vie
votre très humble nicodemus l'inventeur
m'étonne tu vas me rendre heureux mais a
laissé de la felix felicis allez hop
tout ce que j'entreprends draps
aujourd'hui sera couronnée de succès
comme la vue de cette vidéo
c'est le good eye on va écouter tout
seul un peu plus d'une heure parce que
parce que parce que chill aujourd'hui
chill tranquille mais il est
relativement simple d'ailleurs n'oubliez
jamais le prix d'un cas ce n'était pas
forcément en corrélation avec son niveau
de difficulté je contrainte d'avoir été
le premier à l'essayer merci beaucoup du
coup la boutique je raconte de
doué-la-fontaine de m'avoir autorisé à
le tester et puis encore une fois bravo
à l'aps terium je mets un lien de delap
terium également dans la destruction si
vous voulez voir un peu leur travail de
dingue quant à vous si vous voulez qu'on
se croise il reste là c'est les deux
derniers mois de la tournée de en
création donc la cds les dernières dates
en fait la version définitive de en
création n'hésitez pas à passer parce
qu'après c'est terminé je ne manquerai
pas sur scène avant fin 2022 et encore
ce sera du coup avec le tout nouveau
spectacle vous avez aussi bien dans la
description prenez soin de vous pensez à
vous abonner si vous kiffez les casse
tête parce que jean feltain sur cette
chaîne bientôt les deux millions
d'abonnés à très bientôt ciao